I think I'm the only academic speaking
here at the conference so I want to
actually talk to you though about a real
database new data system we're building
at Carnegie Mellon and we're actually
spending the time to do what I consider
high quality engineering within academia
to put the system out there and have it
actually be usable outside of our
research group and so the system is
called peloton and we're pitching this
so it's making this system different
from what's already out there is that
this is the first self-driving database
management system so I'll explain what
that is in a second but before I talk
about the new system I want to spend a
little time talking about how I got to
the point where we're now studying or
researching this particular problem so
my background is when I was in graduate
school I helped build a new Didius
minute system called H store if you
never heard me H store that's fine right
it's there's a Wikipedia article that I
wrote but it's it's okay but you may
have had you heard of both dB and so H
store is actually the academic
predecessor of volt dB
so they took our code they forked it and
they formed the company bolt and so a
CRM volte be our database managed
systems that are designed for
high-throughput transaction processing
and that's what they were designed it's
designed to do above everything else so
they didn't care about doing OLAP they
ain't care about doing more complex
analytics it's purely trying to get fast
transactional performance and there's
probably the best systems out there now
that can do this so what happened though
because we had this incessant drive just
get better and better all to be
performance I got in a little bit of
trouble because I end up getting
addicted to trying to get high
transaction throughput and I to the
detriment of my health my relationships
and my family I did this over but you
know I I worried about this research
problem with you know in the lieu of
everything else so now that I've gone to
rehab and now that I've talked it over
with my sponsor I'm actually gonna share
with you guys the experience that I had
of how we you know I got in trouble with
these systems so it all started in 2008
when we had the first demo of H store
and this is actually me and one of the
first engineers at bolte be showing our
support system to do at vo DB in New
Zealand
and so for this initial prototype of the
system we can do 5,000 transactions a
second on about two laptops now like
today's standard this doesn't seem like
much but yet the under scene at the time
the best that my sequel in Postgres
could do for TPCC was maybe 400 500
transactions a second and then a
well-tuned oracle box to do about 900
whereas we were a bunch of academics and
we were able to write a system that
could do 5000 so I'll never forget when
we've turned the system on the first
time that feeling about it got this rush
that came of my body when I saw the
performance and we were able to achieve
and so I wanted to get that same high
over and over again right so I just kept
trying to make my system better and
better to try to get this number and get
that same feeling I had the first time
so in 2010 we had a later prototype of
the system we were able to do 11,000
transactions a second and so people
started notice that I started having
problems I was very obsessed about
getting you know higher throughput
numbers and this is actually picture me
hiding in the bathroom from my advisor
because they try to have an intervention
to say hey maybe you have a problem and
so I was able to avoid that then in 2012
we had another version the system came
out where we can do now fifty thousand
TPCC transactions per second and again
at this point I was a train wreck
I stopped showering I barely ate this
photos me this photo was taken by my
ex-girlfriend when she was trying to
wake me up to go you know go do
something after spending the last three
days just trying to get better
transaction performance and again no
matter what I did no matter how much and
how much we try to optimize the system I
never got that same feeling that I had
from the first time and so sadly I can
admit that I hit rock bottom in 2015
when we had a new prototype system that
can now do four million TPCC
transactions a second so this is the
photo of that the cops took when they
picked me up down by the dumpster like I
said I was completely out of it
so I went through rehab and you know
what and now I feel like I'm strong
enough to say that yes I did have a
problem I was addicted to transaction
performance and after working through
you know our counselor and everything
I'm now realized that just trying to get
better transaction performance over
everything else
ultimately leaves two unfulfilled
lifestyle because no matter what you do
there's always something else you can do
to make make the system go faster right
there's you can always try to get an
extra 100,000 transactions a second and
there's always new hardware coming out
that's gonna make things go faster and
now what I realized is that this is the
only thing that I focus on I just like
chasing the pink dragon you're just
never gonna get it because it keeps
going farther and farther away and so
now when I went to rehab and now
recognize that I should look at other
other other problems to try to help the
world in other ways so when I got out of
rehab last year it was right around the
time that there was this announcement
where Apple had purchased a database
company called foundation DB and if you
know what you don't remember what
foundation DB was they were a no Seco
distribute key value store sort of
similar to what the cockroach guys are
talked about today and so this is kind
of a big deal because Apple bought a
database company and then they it was it
was closed source to begin with and so
they sort of made it more secretive
because they didn't talk about what they
were actually doing so the fact that
Apple bought this transaction company
transaction database company isn't that
interesting from my perspective what was
actually for the more interesting are
the hacker news comments where people
were saying lamenting the fact that
there was no good open source
transactional database system that could
replace foundation DB now this is well
before I think cockroach came along but
P were saying look best you can do now
is basically shard my sequel Pro scratch
yourself but that's kind of a pain to do
and then the other thing I saw but
there's a lot of comments where people
are saying lamenting the fact that
maintaining database software was really
expensive and difficult to do so this
particular person is saying the
enterprise DB guys so the commercial
vendor or the commercial support company
for Postgres wouldn't even talk to them
unless they put down $10,000 for a
contract to basic do you know taste
basic database administration stuff on
their cluster so this is sort of the
problem that I foresee that that there's
all these people that are paying a lot
of money to have people basically
maintain their database software and it
may be sometimes you have money on
somebody on staff who's a DBA that has
experience through this but often the
case it falls on someone who actually
you know is it as a developer but maybe
use the database at their last job and
so they can maybe know something about
how
how to tune the system and make it
actually work so part of the problem of
all this is that simply database
administrators are very expensive so
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics as of last year a mid-level
to senior database administrator DBA
salary was about eighty one thousand
dollars a year and this is across the
entire country I know for a fact that in
talking with DBA is here in New York
City they're making well over six
figures right and especially some of the
financial firms these things who range
up to about five hundred thousand
dollars a year and you think about it
what the database administrator is doing
you're basically paying somebody to
babysit software write their check and
me see what indexes are there the check
and see whether the system is running
correctly they're just a human being
checking to make sure this really
expensive software that holds all your
data is working as expected and so this
is the problem we're trying to solve
with a self-driving database manner
system is that we're gonna develop a new
system that's able to do all the things
that a human DBA can do now
automatically so it means we could be
able to configure tune and optimize the
system without requiring a human to make
any decision about whether those you
know what whether those are the right
choices to make and so the kind of
things that we think are self-driving
databases support or they're sort of
classic problems the classic things that
again human DBAs are doing now so things
like physical database design picking
indexes picking materialized views
partitioning data data placements and
moving data between different nodes to
balance things out query optimization
sort of when a query runs slow figuring
out why went slower and make decisions
on how to speed things up knob
configuration would be some sort of
setting buffer pool sizes and cache
sizes backup and recovery and
provisioning so now the things that we
think a self-driving database immune
system can't do or anything that
requires a human to make a value
judgment about the choice so anything
for example that was security and apples
we're not gonna be able to do because
the system's not gonna be able to infer
from the application what's the correct
thing to do so for example if Wesley
gets fired from his company on Friday
the dating business was not gonna know
that come Monday he shouldn't have
access to it right this is something a
human has to tell us so the things on
the this side here under know these are
things you're still need to pay a DBA to
do cuz this involves getting decisions
within the company at a human resource
level but anything from a technical
standpoint in terms
optimizing database system we think our
new system can handle that so now you
may be thinking well haven't I heard
this already isn't this sort of the
basic guide story of database systems
from the 1970s right and the whole pitch
about using declarative language like
sequel was that we wanted that prevent
programmers from having to write join
algorithms by hand and will let the
database system have an optimizer pick
the correct query plan to do so I would
and certainly in the last 15 to 20 years
Microsoft did a lot of stuff and with
the auto admin project of coming up with
sort of index advisory tools and other
things like that and of course Oracle
and IBM sell similar products so what I
would say what's different about what
we're doing now versus what's already
been done is all those previous tools
are all reactive and human driven so
what usually happens is you for the
index stuff the index advisory tools the
DBA has to prepare a workload tray so
here's all the queries that I've run in
the past and here's the one that ran
slow you feed that into the tool and the
tool complex says well here's the
indexes I think you need to add and then
it's still up to the human aside not
only whether to apply but the
suggestions and make the changes to the
database but also to know when to do
that right for example DBAs know that
Sunday at 3 a.m. is when your
application doesn't see a lot of traffic
so that's what you can go ahead and
build indexes so in our self-driving
database system not only do we have to
be able to make the same optimization
choices that the current tools can do
but we also have to predict what's
coming down the pipeline for the
application and to know what we need
prepare ourselves for but then also to
infer from the workload we've seen in
the past when's the right time to apply
these optimizations so again using the
Sunday a Sunday morning example so the
reason why this is now possible is that
there's been enough recent advancements
in both the storage and computational
hardware as well as algorithmic
advancements with deep learning where we
can actually apply a lot of the
techniques that are people are using
today for self-driving cars and use them
within the self-driving database system
so things like the GPUs and larger
memory capacities that allow us to store
more data and process it to build the
models for what our applications going
to do so the system that we're building
to try out this idea is called peloton
so if you're not familiar with the term
peloton it's a French word that means
platoon and it basically has to do when
you have bicycles racing in like that
one big game they pack together as they
go around the velodrome today reduce the
wind resistance for everyone so this is
basic basic idea we want to do in our
database system we want to have the
system use multiple nodes work together
to make the system overall the overall
system work faster so as I said we're
trying to make the system be usable
outside of CMU so this is apache license
open source we speak that we try to be
Postgres compatible and we're spending
the time to actually you know do write
the things you would actually need to do
to run this in production and not just
be sort of research prototype that we
you need to write papers so there's sort
of four main tenets or pillars of the
peloton project that I want to talk
about a little bit but I'll focus on the
autonomous piece at the end so the first
is that peloton uses an in-memory
architecture so that means that the
primary storage little case primary
storage location of the database is
assumed to be entirely in DRAM so if you
make this choice allows you to optimize
a buncha different aspects of the system
like it's concurrent role scheme and
logging scheme that you would not be
able to do in a traditional disk based
system like in Postgres or my sequel
Oracle so now there's a whole other
Avenue of research we're doing this as
well where we're building system beat
will take advantage of the new emerging
non-volatile memory technologies that
are coming out there it's like
memristors and phase change memory those
things like that so we have papers on
that if you're interested but basically
what I'll say is that we're designing
the system in such a way that when this
MVM stuff found becomes available you
could plop it in the system and are what
we would be able to use it automatically
to extend the address space of the
database or the data base process right
and the things like with Postgres on my
sequel and oracle you're not gonna be
able to do that very easily because they
you know be are assuming they're using
slow base slow disk systems or SSDs so
the other aspect of our system that's
relevant is that we're designing this
thing to be a hybrid system or H tab
system so that means within this single
single database instance you can run all
the fast transactions you put Iran in
like a bowl tv-style system as well as
do all the analytics that you'd want to
do in like a spark a green plum a
vertical or a redshift system and so you
can we can do this in such a way where
the analytical operations don't slow
down the transactions from updating the
database so it allows you do not not
have to worry about using the ETL
process the shove all the data from your
front and transactional database to your
back-end data warehouse you can do
everything in a single box
the next piece that's relevant to us is
that we have a execution engine that's
using the LLVM to do query compilation
it is my opinion that if any any if you
ever have a data warehouse you have to
do cogeneration of query compilation to
get the good performance and so we we
use the LLVM to make this possible the
only other two systems that we know
about the do the similar also use the LM
m to do this would be mem sequel and the
German hyper system that tableau bought
last year so what this allows you to do
instead of generating a query plan tree
like you would do if you've ever took an
intraday introduction a database course
and then they have to traverse and
interpret the tree you basically compile
the query into machine code and execute
it directly and in some cases that you
can get a hundred X speed-up over the
sort of traditional model and then the
last piece is that's a ton of stuff that
I'll to focus on for the rest of the
talk
so what I'll say is that for all the
other things the LLVM the hybrid stuff
and the in-memory stuff these are
necessary for us to be able to do the
otama stuff that that I'm gonna talk
about next because if you have a slow
disk based system like on my Segal or
Postgres or an Oracle then you
essentially have an 18-wheeler that is
not gonna be able to be very nimble and
agile and make changes quickly based on
what the database system is observing in
your application and so only because we
have these other parts is gonna make
this autonomous stuff possible so the
core thing that we're building to do the
self-driving control of the system is
what we're essentially calling the brain
so we originally wanted to call the
system the entire system the brain but
obviously Google brain would would
interfere with that and be difficult to
find us on a search engine so the brain
is essentially is an integrated D
planning framework that's embedded
inside the database system that monitors
the workload of the queries that your
application executes and then builds
models based on what it sees and then
runs an optimization I when I figure out
what actions it wants to take to improve
the the latency of the throughput of the
system and so I want to go sort of
high-level overview how this works and
I'll show a some experimental results to
showing you what we can do with this so
the database system the the brain part
is going to be monitoring the
applications workload so observing all
the queries that it executes
and in the first phase is going to use
an unsupervised clustering algorithm to
break the queries up into buckets based
on similar features so the features
could be like what tables that they
access what tables that they modify you
know what kind of query operation they
were doing as well as physical metrics
like what how many rows did the access
or how many - how many records that they
modify and now for each of these buckets
we're gonna we're gonna generate a time
series graph that corresponds to the
number of queries that occurred for that
bucket across different horizons so the
example I'm showing here we have a 24
hour a 7 day and a 48 horizon and the
idea here is for the for the more
shorter horizons like in a 24 hour case
we'll keep we'll keep intervals that we
use more fine-grain intervals to keep
track of all the queries that we execute
on a per minute basis but in the longer
term horizon like in the 40 days ok so
we don't really care about how many
queries you expect to execute on a
permanent basis 30 days from now so
we'll use something like aren't hourly
or - our basis so now for each of these
time series we'll feed this into
tensorflow
to build recurrent neural network so
long term long short term memory
recurrent neural networks so we don't
know anything about deep learning the
only thing you need to know is that
there's essentially two type of neural
networks there's the convolution ones
and that's what they use for the image
recognition and then there's the
recurrent neural networks and that's the
one you use for time series analysis or
stock analysis like we're doing here so
we're gonna build some some neural
networks for each of our time series and
that's gonna allow us to model and
predict what we think the workloads
gonna look like in the future and we're
gonna want to do this for every single
bucket that we have so then now we feed
this into the optimization component
where we're gonna figure out what
actions we want to take to make the
databases of databases run faster so the
first part if you have this cattle
overall that these different actions and
a history of what happened when we try
to run them before so if it'd be a list
of all the indexes we could possibly add
and if we ever try to add one do we say
well when we added it did it make things
better to make things worse and then
we're gonna feed this into a tree search
algorithm on Monte Carlo tree search
algorithm to figure out a sequence of
actions that we want to apply for for
our given database state at that moment
and then
we have a cost benefit or cost model
that allows us to determine for every
single action is this you know how long
it's gonna take for us to deploy it and
what benefit is the database system
gonna get from it so at the end of the
day what we want to do is action
sequence of all the actions we want to
take from now until at some point in the
future and then what we end up doing is
we oak we end up throwing away all the
actions but the first one will only
apply it and then come back and do this
whole entire process all over again so I
want to force the metaphor too much but
this is essentially what the
self-driving cars are doing the
self-driving car looks as far can it can
down the road and then plans a bunch of
action sequence plans an action sequence
that's going to get it to that end of
the horizon but then what happens is it
ends up throwing away all but the first
action applies it and it comes back and
does all this planning over again so in
the terms of reinforcement learning this
is called proceeding receding horizon
action planning so this is essentially
what we want to do but we and unlike the
self-driving car it doesn't every you
know once thirty times a second we our
time frame is a bit longer here so an
action could be like added index drop in
index make this change move data around
but then we would only apply the first
one come back and evaluate whether we
that helped us out or not and again we
have sort of this this feedback
mechanism for every action that we take
we check to see whether that was a good
choice or not all right so for for the
evaluation what I want to show is two
parts I want to show that there are
forecasting models can accurately
predict what we think of database
workload is going to look like and then
I want to show how we can use this
information to automatically optimize
the layout of the database so for this
we don't actually have any customers yet
or any real users because this is still
an academic prototype but for this we
have a synthetic workload that's based
on the some public traffic data from
from reddit so we're gonna build to rnns
or to for current neural networks using
tensor flow for this so the first one
we're gonna generate a 21 out of horizon
at one-minute intervals and so the only
thing you can be mindful of here is that
there's the red line is the actual
workload what what the database system
actually executed and then the blue line
is what we predicted what would happen
and so if you sort of squint you can see
that we get the major trends correctly
right and this is pretty good this is
what we actually need to do for the
system to do so in our case our air rate
is around fifteen percent and in terms
of the recurrent neural networks
anything less than twenty percent is
good enough for us and so for this we're
actually using the CPU to do the
computation and tensorflow so it takes
about 25 minutes for us to build this
build this model we just got our new GT
X 1080 last week so hopefully we can run
this in the Jeep and the GPU and get
lower numbers but the main things that
we actually care about is that the probe
time and the update time are are really
small so it only takes this two
milliseconds to probe our model and
figure out what we think the workloads
gonna be and that's pretty fast and then
it only takes those five milliseconds to
take a new interval of a new batch of
queries that we just executed and do the
back propagation in the model to update
it to keep us moving for at a time so in
this example here we're doing one minute
interval so that means every minute we
only have to spend five milliseconds to
update the model and always keep it in
sync with what be a sex application is
actually doing so now when you look at a
more longer horizon here we're doing 24
hour horizon with one minute intervals
and again the same thing we get the
major trends correctly and but our air
rate is a little bit higher or now about
18% but their CPU training time is less
because there's less data that we're
keeping track of on apperent per per
animal basis so the last thing I'll
point out too is that both these cases
the neural network has around two
megabytes in size and it doesn't seem
like a lot but be mine be mindful of the
fact that we are an in-memory database
so every any bit of memory using for
these models takes away from data we can
actually store and then we add so let's
keep keep multiple models for every
single bucket that we generate so we
could have potentially too many of these
so this is a certain area where I think
the algorithms tough the algorithm work
that people are doing in deep learning
is gonna catch up and help us out here
so for example there's a bunch of
techniques that people are working on
now to reduce the the how much data
you're storing on a you know per weight
basis so these are using like 32-bit or
64-bit weights but some people do some
work on sixteen you're dropping down to
sixteen good weights there's other
techniques you can do to also compress
the the neural network by you know
reducing the number of layers you have
by just sort of shrinking them so we
think when those things come out that'll
help us out too and hopefully tends to
flow just gets them alright so now that
we have these models what we
actually do with them so I want to show
you a technique that we've had built
inside of our system but it allows to do
AB dapped of storage so what this means
that we're gonna change the actual
physical layout of the data over time
based on how queries are actually going
to execute it so I'll give an example so
say we have in our simple application we
have two queries we have an OLTP
transactional query that wants to update
up to the table and then we have a OLAP
query that want to compute some kind of
aggregate over a large portion of the
data so typically what happens in the
sort of hybrid applications is that
there's some hot data that all the
transactions are trying to update in
access and in the OTP portion of the
workload and then there's this cold data
that is read mostly a read only that the
analytical queries are going to operate
on so what happens if when you actually
look in the actual queries themselves
they'll see you in the OTP queries
they're usually accessing all of the
rector the columns or the attributes of
the table but in OLAP queries they
typically access some subset of them so
we're gonna do the system's we on a
categorize our data to be either hot or
cold for now we're just assuming that
it's a you know it's either hot or cold
and not in sort of a continuous
distribution aisle but but we could
change that without any issues and then
for each for the hot and cold data we'll
figure out what's the optimal layout for
our table that's gonna be get the best
performance for the queries that execute
on these segments of the table so in the
case of the hot data we want to keep
everything still as a row store because
the queries are accessing all the
attributes and it doesn't make sense to
actually split them up but in the case
of the cold data we want to recognize
that the column B and C are used
together so we want to store them
continuously as column segments and
we'll store a and D separately so this
allows you get the benefit of being our
column store because you don't read data
that you don't have to process data or
bring that in to your CPU caches even
though you're actually never going to
need them for the query so this is
essentially allows to still get the
benefit of having a roast or to do fast
transactions as you would in like a
volte b or x 10 system but then also do
have a column store that make the
analytical queries go faster so
currently no system can is actually able
to do this automatically in the way that
we are so in the case of mem sequel that
you can manually declare that a table is
either a roast or a column store and you
have to mainly move data from one one
segment to the neck so what
won't do this automatically the case SCP
Hana the same thing they actually have
two different execution engines and
storage engines that'll manage the road
data in the store and the column data
separately whereas in our system it's
completely uniform layout or keep me
completely uniform system that can deal
with both these types of these data
formats so to see what kind of benefit
you can get from this I have a simple
micro benchmark where we are gonna take
the Reta traffic data we have and sort
of model an application where during the
day time we're doing heavy inserts
because people are inserting new
comments and then at night we do more
decision support or lap type workload
where we do complete scans over large
portions of the data and we're gonna
compare our adaptive layout running in
the autonomous with autonomous system
with a system that does static row
layout and Static column layout so in
the first case and so we're gonna divide
up our each day and T the scan portion
of the insert portion of the workload so
in the case of the row layout what you
see is that the scans keep getting
slower as as more data gets inserted
because it's ending at ending up having
to read more and more data I said this
is sort of this is not anything novel
does not anything new this has been
shown before that column stories will
get better performance to do these kind
of operations in the column store case
is actually reversed the scans are much
faster because it's only reading the
data that actually needs to process the
query but the inserts are slower because
you have to take a single tuple and
break it up into two different
attributes and do multiple memory memory
rights to write out the columns so the
scans actually the inserts are slower
than in case the roast or in the case of
our active adapted layout system what we
see is that when we start off where we
get the same performance as the row
store because we just loaded the
database in we didn't execute any
queries so of course everything was
automatically stored as a row in the
rows of rows store format but then the
system recognizes that the the queries
that are operating on the pickup
portions of the table would benefit from
having a column store layout so it
automatically migrates or invokes
actions that migrate the data from the
row store layout to the column store
layout so use the application you don't
know this is happening because you're
still dealing with a single logical
table a single logical database but
underneath the covers the database
system is managing different physical
segments based on what layout is best
for that type of query and so what you
see is is now
that as the data migrates from the from
a row layout to a column layout we can
get just as you can get the same
performance if not better than the pure
column store but when it comes time to
insert new tuples we get the same
performance you get in the row store so
again this is allowing to have us to
have beth the best of both worlds in a
single database system we can support
both types of layouts and the system is
doing this automatically underneath the
covers without you as to human habitats
tell us anything about what your
application actually wants okay so the
cell sounds great and I would love for
you guys to view and try it out and your
applications it's truth be told we're
not actually ready yet so currently we
are only we only support a single node
operation and we're not actually to put
this in production in any meaningful way
but we are very interested in talking
anybody here that actually want to try
this thing out maybe hopefully getting
some the problems you have in your robot
applications because I talked enough few
companies to know what you guys actually
want I'm happy to say also to you that
everything we're doing is Apache License
2.0 right nothing is proprietary that
we're doing everything everything's
don't get hub and everything's out in
the public
but please do talk to me if you guys
actually won't try this out okay so I'm
actually the the website is available
online you can go check out some basic
information about what's going on and
again there's a link to github and a
documentation about how we actually do
some of these things and those papers
coming out within the next few months
about describing the full architecture
in more detail so mob see not doing this
in the vacuum I have an awesome team
back at CMU made a bunch of students
masters master students PhD students and
postdocs that are helping me build this
thing and again we're actually spending
the time they actually do you know good
coding or good high quality engineering
within academia to make sure this thing
doesn't crash and burn when it goes out
301 and actually use this system as the
basis for all my projects in my graduate
Davis course on a graduate course on
database internals so all the students
have to do projects and involve our
system so I mean thank you for your time
but have any any questions about about
the palestine project hey you
yes
the no will network learn something
weird and you know take some action in
the ends up hurting performance or you
know does something disastrous right so
his question is this all sounds fine and
dandy but what happens when the the
neural network gets it wrong right what
do you do so there is we haven't done
this yet but at some point there
probably will need to be an override
switch where if a human does decide that
it wants to do something that the data
system doesn't want it to do then the
human would take preference over that
but we think that the right way to do
this is actually any action that a human
specifies would have a TTL what a time
to live so that way if it was the
correct action that system would learned
it oh yes this is actually what I want
to do and keep it if it's the wrong
action then it can correct it and and
and fix it later on another aspect that
we haven't quite considered how to
support just yet is different
applications have different performance
metrics that they care about and
currently our system cares about
reducing late latency of transactions of
queries and the issue with that is the
the kind of benefit or it could be the
benefit your your organization or
application would get from reducing the
latency of an old feed transaction is
probably much higher than you get from
reducing the latency of a Oh without
query so for example if your transaction
goes from 100 milliseconds to 50
milliseconds that's a huge win allows
you to do things maybe you couldn't do
before but if your if your OLAP queries
goes from you know one second to 500
milliseconds that isn't that big of a
deal right but in terms of absolute
performance it's a bigger drop than the
OTP case so the system may end up trying
to optimize that and we don't know how
to maybe handle that maybe it's a big
knob you say prefer OTP versus OLAP the
bottom line is we don't want the human
map to do any labeling for us to say
optimize this don't optimize that we
hopefully the system configured all this
out the in terms of we think it's good
we think that you know this is part of
it has just started we think that in the
long term the the neural networks would
be good enough that you would never
question it right it's sort of like the
same I don't again don't wanna force the
metaphor too much but it sort of like
the self-driving car when they first
come out people were to be super worried
about them
but over the years as they get vetted
and getting better and better and better
then people won't even think about just
trusting you know a system or automated
system to take care of everything that's
where I want to end up but it's fully
met we're not there yet
so his question is it's an Emory
database system is their ability to take
a snapshot right about the disk and
possibly load it back in later
absolutely so we I mean the standard we
use the standard sort of write ahead
logging approach where you you you write
it you write out the physical updates to
the database to a writer head log and
then ever so often you take a periodic
check point right that's sort of
standard practice in the database system
single node right yes so what would you
need to do to make it multi node there's
question is what do we need to do what
do we need to do to make it multi node
in terms of the autonomous stuff for the
actual full-tilt our data system alright
so this question is what do we need to
do to make the autonomous stuff
distributed so so the thing that we what
we let me go distribute it one thing
we're considering is that and maybe you
dedicate one machine to be the brain
brain that controls the entire cluster
and in that case you need a little ship
efficiently streams to the to that brain
about what is actually executing at that
particular node right and in that case
the this the only thing that really
changes is making sure you keep that
thing coordinated and in sync with
everybody else I said so the but the I
don't it's my impression that the
algorithms don't change you add
additional actions to do provisioning
and other things that you wouldn't do in
a single node case but I think the
overall pipeline that I described with
the Tres is going to forecast new models
are and then you use them in a receiving
action horizon planning or receiving
horizon action planning system I think
that all stays the same do you think
what one database brain could learn I'm
sorry one brain of one instance could
learn it's transferable to another
instance so his question is is it
possible to have one database instance
train models that could then be
transferable to two other models we are
actually working on another project
that's sort of similar to this and our
findings are possibly no so we have
another project where we can take
streaming traces or we take
metrics that collected from the database
system feed that into a model and then
if you come along with your new
application that we haven't seen before
we try to map you to an application that
we've seen in the past and says we know
how to tune that one we can help you to
your new one the issue that we're
finding though is that it's very
sensitive to the hardware so if you have
say you need me have possibly it's the
two same database applications just
running on different hardware and you'd
make different design choices based on
that so it may not be possible what we
think we're how this would actually work
is that hopefully we maybe train some
basic models at you know at CMU that
would be provided to you when you use
our system but then for your local
system it gets better and better and
better on its own learning what's going
on is localized environment so the the
main main answer is the horror makes a
big difference and it's hard to
extrapolate from that how to extend it
from you know from one neck next and
that's actually a whole other facet of
deep learning that's called knowledge
transfer that is beyond my what I can do
yeah have you explored the avenue of
using neural networks to optimize the
data model itself as opposed to just
slapping indices on tables because that
can often improve performance itself see
your question is could you use a neural
network to optimize the data model so
what do you like like the relational
model or what do you would like the
logical schema the problem is modifying
the logical schema is that it you would
have to rewrite the application right so
for example if you take if you do D
normalization or normalization you take
a table split it up into two different
things then you have to go rewrite your
application to go now do joins now you
can hide that with the view but in that
case you're modifying the physical
layout right so you it's more maybe
maybe your your correct question does
not change the logical schema but change
the physical design and we're absolutely
doing that right so we can do a
decomposition to say all right well this
this table can really be broken up to
chunks and because that because I have a
large in a blob field of our binary that
maybe one I want to store on the side
and then I have an abstraction layer
that knows that it's a it's a single
logical table that's now broken I'm
fever two different parts right there's
no reason we can't do
we for a current version we don't
support that do you do you do anything
so suppose that your system says oh you
know I think that building this index
would be a good idea do you do anything
clever to cut down on the amount of time
that it might take to build a thing and
test it out because you know like it
might be like an hour to construct an
indexer sprite so your question is do we
do any optimizations to make the next
pill to go faster so we it's not
published yet we're actually working on
a technique now where we allowed we can
build our indexes incrementally in a
non-blocking fashion and it's more than
just building the index anchor mentally
and it's actually providing feedback up
to the query optimizer to know hey
there's this index you can use it if you
you can use it even those partially
built for some queries but not all of
them so the way my sequel and all these
systems work now is do you build the
index and it can't be used by any query
until it's actually done and finished
where our new quote of our new mechanism
allows you to build it and even though
it may take an hour halfway through you
can still actually start using this and
speed up queries we get to be careful
make sure you know how many false
negatives and false positives so it's
more than this you know building the
index incremental e it's making the
entire stack of the system know that
that's going on right and be aware of
that and then make decisions based on
based on that
so some real assistance when development
time and staging and deploying the uses
patent and data pattern and query panel
my very very differently
like what's the logistics kind of
because you need real data and assume
the distribution of data is the same to
train the model to make correct
decisions and what's the logistics when
our developers do something which the
users patent we're different from
deployment so your question is say ear
on a dev machine to test things out and
the developers are doing queries in one
way with some sample database and then
when you actually run in production the
the distribution the cardinality of
values are completely different and
acquit and the workloads actually and
different and from our perspective there
was those to be separate database
instances and we the the the you know
the production instance doesn't know
about the development one so it's not
going to make any optimization decisions
based on what you did in dev because it
only does what it does in production
right answer his sort of relate to his
question the developer ain't come along
say well when in my dev environment
this index really help I want to use
that if you tell us you want to create
index we'll do it but we'll mark that it
was a human made that decision not us
and then we'll check overtime whether
that was the right thing or not
a problem that comes up frequently with
machine learning which is neural
networks is the difficulty of explaining
why a decision was made have you guys
done any work on did enemies saying well
you know that thing that was a hundred
milliseconds now it takes fifty but why
what did I do yeah so this question is
deep learning is awesome it can be
magical sometimes but it doesn't really
tell you why it made the decisions
absolutely so we we have thought about
this we haven't done anything yet
this is sort of actually one of the big
problems that people have a deep
learning now is like it's a totally a
black box stuff comes in magic comes out
but no one you understand what was going
on right because if you actually look at
the neural network it's just a bunch of
weights doesn't mean anything so yes we
have thought about this I don't want to
say anything specific because it's
probably gonna be incorrect ultimately
where we want to go go is that when we
make an action it's gonna have it a
human-readable explanation to say like
well your your latency was looking like
this and it looked like this in the past
therefore we applied this index so we've
done something similar before and that's
why that's why we made that decision
absolutely we're not there yet and I
think there's there's a much more work
need to be done in deep learning to the
algorithm side of things before that's
actually possible but that's it mate
that's a major problem yes
all right great those are some awesome
questions so we are gonna go on coffee
break and just a reminder Andy's office
hours are after coffee break at 3:15 in
the room across the way all right thank
you very much